there will be nationwide demonstrations
tomorrow over the lack of action
following yet more mass shootings in
this country they are led by march for
our lives which was formed in the
aftermath of the 2018 attack at marjory
stoneman douglas high school in parkland
florida organizers say there will be
more than 450 marches across the united
states the largest is being held at the
washington monument the message to
congress is quote you're killing us with
your inaction
jacqueline corn is one of the founders
of march for our lives and she joins me
here this morning good morning good to
see you good morning thank you for
having me so jaclyn i know you know and
we talked about this earlier and i know
this must be traumatizing uh to see this
happen time and time and time again but
in the wake of uvaldi when you saw the
news breaking about what was going down
in that school and the aftermath what
went through your mind
well
i just knew that it was so reminiscent
of what happened at my high school in
parkland in 2018 i mean you had a
teenager
who should not have access to firearms
getting to walk out of a gun store with
a semi-automatic rifle and using that
weapon to kill innocent children in the
place that they're supposed to be
supposed to feel safest
uh and i just know that the people in
uvalde um must be reeling
after the deaths of 19 children and two
teachers they now have a lifetime ahead
of them of healing and they're going to
face incredible trauma uh similar to
what my friends and i deal with back in
parkland
and it feels though like we've been here
before you know sandy hook
parkland in each of those instances
congress
fails to act you
did this march in the wake of the
shooting at your school nothing happened
are you hopeful that anything will
change this time around
well i wouldn't say nothing happened um
there were actually over 150 state laws
passed after the march and the shooting
at my high school in 2018 and those laws
have saved thousands of lives
collectively it's important to point
that out at the state level there is
action for example here in new york
state just in the wake of vivaldi we've
seen action by the governor exactly and
that state change is really necessary
and we need to see more of it but it's
so important that we see federal change
because of gun trafficking across state
borders
um
you and your classmates were thrust into
the spotlight uh in the wake of your
tragedy how has the group changed how
have you grown since the horrific events
of that day
yeah i after the shooting i pretty much
thrust myself into advocacy because i
knew that if i was lucky enough to
survive the shooting and and some of my
peers were not
i need to do i needed to do something
productive with my fear uh and so i kind
of spent the rest of my high school
career throwing away my the rest of my
childhood really and doing this advocacy
work um but i went to college and i i
took a step back for a time but now you
know in the wake of the valdez shooting
and the buffalo shooting
i think this country is at another um
turning point and i really think this is
uh the time where we're gonna see real
substantial change
um so i'm getting back out there you
know organizing
with my fellow peers at march for our
lives but i've grown so much
you know politically i've come to really
understand the political barriers that
exist in this country which i didn't
know
back then and i know it's tough to
create change but i know it's possible
you know when i meet people like you and
i talk to people like you i know that
it's possible because you and your peers
are going to be the ones that will
change the world for a better place
you're already doing that now thank you
so much for being here with us thank you
for what you're doing thank you